Complexity theory deals a lot with problems and with algorithms,
so we should say a little bit more about each one of the two.
So, a problem normally consists of 3 parts.
The first one is very simple.
It's just a name that we give to the problem so that when we talk about it,
we know how to reference it.
In this case we're going to find a better name for that soon, but in this case,
we'll just call the problem that Alice was working on 'Alice's problem.'
For each problem, we also need to say something about the input
that we're expecting for it.
So in this case, here, it's a network of communication centers.
And, of course, we also need to say something about the output
that we are expecting.
So in this case, here, it would be the minimum number of monitoring devices
to cover all cables or all connections.
Of course the most useful output would be to know not only the minimum number
of monitoring devices, but where we should actually put them.
But you're soon going to see that it doesn't really make much of a difference
most of the time if we are just asking for the minimum number
or if we are actually asking for the communication centers
where we need to put those devices.
Now, what Alice devised to solve this problem was a possible algorithm.
Now, there's no really accepted definition of what an algorithm actually is.
But, for us, it's enough to say that whenever we talk about an algorithm,
we'll be talking about the description of a computer program that is able to solve
the problem that we are given.
Now the question that we want to answer for Alice's problem--
since the algorithm that she has found is not very good--
is if the problem that she's working on is a hard problem or an easy problem.
And what we mean by that is if it's possible to find a more efficient algorithm
for this problem.
If that is the case, then we would call this problem an easy problem.
Or, we will soon have a more precise definition of that, actually.
And if it's not possible to find a better algorithm for the problem,
then this would be considered a hard problem.
Now, the hardness of a problem tells you how fast and with how many resources
you can solve the problem.
But, of course, that would require you to find
the best possible algorithm for that problem.
And 'best' is not a very scientific term, so we'll have to say a little bit more about
the analysis of algorithms.